[MUSIC PLAYING]
DR. BEVIL CONWAYIf I ask you to name
some colors, or the color of a banana,
you would tell me a
banana is yellow, right?
Well this is, like, weird
really, when you think about it.
I don't know about your
house, but in my house
the bananas are green when we buy them.
And then they spend, you
know, a day being yellow.
And then they're, like, brown
spotted and, eventually, black things
before we throw them out.
So in their whole life span they've
spent very little time of their lives
being yellow.
But this is the color we encode.
It's the color we think of.
And in fact, it's so
strong that it's the color
we project onto the world around us.
So color, we know, is not simply
the light hitting our eyes.
Because there's all of these, what we
can think of as cognitive influences
that shape what you
experience out there.
My current favorite example of the
interaction between art practice
and the neuroscience of color is
really a close reading of Matisse.
In many of his finished
canvases he actually
leaves these little white bits of an
unpainted canvas between painted marks.
And it's a discovery he made.
Because by introducing
this little white buffer
you protect from color
contrast-- color induction--
you protect the colored
marks so that they
remain about the same
in the finished painting
as they were when he first made them.
So as he's painting in the studio, and
he wants his apple to stay that color,
he can paint the background
lots of other colors,
and have the apple still stay that
color by just not painting next to it.
Just leaving a little
bit of white around it.
So color contrast is
the simple phenomenon
that is when you when you paint a
mark, the color of the painted mark
changes as you paint the
background around the mark.
And this is a problem that new artists
struggle with-- old artists struggle
with.
And that's because the
color of the background,
unconsciously, is changing the way
in which the color of the foreground
appears.
And our brains do this
effortlessly and unconsciously.
So much so that you don't
even think about the impact
of the surround in shaping your
experience of the object color
that you're attending.
And that discovery, as it
were, by Matisse I think
came about because of,
you know, his struggle
in the studio working with paint.
Working with a visual system
that has particular constraints
on the way in which it computes
light information to generate color.
And the consequence on art
history is that, you know,
it changed forever how
we think about art.
How we think about paint.
How we think about what paintings are.
We see that legacy in Rothko, where
now he's gotten rid of everything
except paint and canvas.
Just large fields of color.
And at the time that
Matisse was working that
would have been considered
completely crazy.
Like, literally-- like, I
don't know what that is.
So you see, you know, the impact
of these choices on art practice.
The impact those choices make on
the trajectory of our tradition.
Western art history tradition.
But they also, in this wonderful
way, produce this other discovery.
Which is that color is
divorced from shape.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Matisse shows us--
and then is extended
through Rothko-- shows us that you can
take color completely out of shape.
The banana's color doesn't have
to be attached to the banana.
You can have a field of yellow,
you can have a shape of a banana.
The fact that we experience
those things together
happens because of, probably,
something statistical
about their co-occurrence in the world.
Not because of something fundamental
about their yoking in our brains.
Because if they were
fundamentally yoked in our brains,
we would never be able to see the Rothko
as a field of red divorced from shape.